[Music]
did you know Android has built-in
antivirus protection that gets more
powerful every second it starts when an
Android developer uploads their app to
Google Play a self-learning at risk
analyzer scans
and simulates apps looking for potential
security issues if there's an issue the
app will appear in Google Play on
Android devices verify apps regularly
scan for harmful behavior warning users
and then sending this information to the
analyzer so it keeps getting smart
safety net also scans devices for
exploits and Network vulnerabilities
protecting wasn't 1 billion devices
daily and again sending data back for
the analyzer to get your console and
routing Google Play constantly make your
mobile device paper at home
course and everywhere in between well a
good afternoon I hope the video has
given you a clue as to which session
yeren
this talk is going to be about Google
security services for Android my name is
Debra Cunningham and I'm a product
manager on the Android security team so
I hope that some of you may have caught
the tork yesterday by Adrienne Ludwig
who leaves Android security talking
about the overview of Android security
and it's and its position in the
ecosystem if you didn't catch that I
recommend going and checking out the
video that will be online I'll begin
with a bit of an introduction that helps
frame where Google's services for
Android security fit in and there'll be
lots of time at the end for questions
say I we can have a good discussion
Android has become
a part of the fabric of our daily lives
and nearly all of us interact with
Android in some form each day whether
that's through the phone you use 85% of
smart phones are Android phones or
perhaps the phone or someone you
communicate with or maybe the TV you
have I could be running Android or the
point-of-sale system that you use in a
store you visit and securing all of
these devices and different use cases is
what many of us at Google on the Android
security team get excited by each day as
our mission but it's not just googles
jobs ensuring and driving the security
of the each system is something that is
performed by our partners OMS
enterprises and developers too so
improving the security of this fast
ecosystem is an exciting challenge in
this talk I'm gonna give you an insight
into some of Google's many services for
Android security and give specific
examples of ways that you could take
advantage of these services the Android
ecosystem consists of many millions of
devices and apps and use cases but at
its core consists of the people who use
them Android likely has the most diverse
set of users of any computing platform
today and the range of threats that they
encounter drives their security models
and the protections we put in place I
wonder at one end of the spectrum we
have those who face perhaps the most
advanced adversary's the likes of world
leaders who are investing hundreds of
thousands of dollars to protect their
communications and last year we heard
that President Obama had started using
Android phone for his presidential
communications and his successor appears
to have done likewise but of course
Android security can't just be about
those who can afford to pay a premium
for security Android phones are a
critical lifeline for many of the most
oppressed groups and persecuted people
in the
world today such as refugees you could
be fleeing from oppressive regimes
Android brings them a way to communicate
to navigate and it includes powerful
security protections for those who can't
afford to pay an extra dollar euro or
pound for for that that's security
another example where the security
guarantees in Android are driving new
new businesses and use cases is in the
realm of gaming seems like you see in
the middle here our common last summer
when the Pokemon go phenomenon kicked
off now the core of pokemons for pokemon
goes business model is a sophisticated
approach to detecting abuse and many
other games rely on this similarly
specifically Pokemon go uses Google's
API is on Android to detect fraudulent
users and devices who would be
performing fraud in their game and
you'll seen at the talk yesterday that
all Android devices have a common set of
security properties this is what we
described as a platform security this is
built into the Android Open Source
project the foundational layers of
security this includes things like
application isolation the key part of
this is the sand boxes that protect apps
make sure the data inside apps is for
the app to use only from another app can
tear into the data from any other app
device integrity is important features
like verified boot ensure the integrity
of the system partition with
cryptographic checks and data encryption
full disk encryption make sure that the
data user data is protected Android has
advanced exploit mitigation features
things like address space layout
randomization or integer overflow
protection ensure that it's hard to
exploit vulnerabilities in the platform
even if they are present
and lastly management capabilities
Android is built powerful capabilities
such as work profiles or
administrative ad is to allow you to
manage devices and there's also
important in in be able to deploy
Android devices in many different use
cases such as your enterprise so across
all modern Android phones there's a
relatively uniform set of capabilities
in fact it could be said that across
Android and iOS and Chrome OS all modern
mobile operating systems a set of
capabilities is pretty pretty similar
and this is how the future of client
computing is being being shaped Android
is one of the key parts of Android I
guess is the research community around
it being an open-source program we have
hundreds of researchers developers
around the world contributing to that
security last year androids
vulnerability rewards program paid out
over a million dollars to researchers
and as we build this ecosystem of
research and development around Android
security we're bringing Android to new
heights of security as we grow this
protection year-on-year
through the platform releases on top of
this solid foundation Google builds
security services to protect users from
the risks they might face building
services on top of platform there's at
Google's core like Google wasn't
originally a platform provider and so
this is something that's been built into
Android from the very first minute and
this is where safety net comes in Satan
is the collection of services that
Google builds and freely deploys to
protect users and keeps the system safe
our mission is to protect Android users
with data-driven security apps and
services and this is what we're going to
look at in this session we provide
comprehensive endpoint protection
out-of-the-box from the very first
moment of user starts using their device
they should have all the necessary
protections in place to be and feel safe
the out-of-the-box part is very
important to us we don't think a user
should ever need to go and invest more
money in security once they got their
devices it's a fundamental part of of
Android it would be sad and feud's go
and paid $100 $200 even more if your
phone but then people need to to pay ten
dollars every month to get security but
what we have here was safety net offers
that built-in so taking that broadly
maps into four segments and this roughly
forms the agenda for this this talk and
we're going to look at some of these in
detail first verify apps and this is
what most people's minds jump to when
they think about Google's security
services for Android this is in the
realm of harmful app detection
prevention and removal I'll show you
some new features and verify apps and
even some some API to that you could use
then we have the sensor network which is
rather more elusive and this is our
privacy preserving security analytics
and telemetry framework built into every
Android device this is how we can see
across the Android ecosystem the health
of Android devices it allows us to
monitor the behavior of rats and see
when things step out of line
and when something unusual happens on
the device we can use this sensor
network to route calls that change and
then go and remediate where we are able
the sensor network observes things like
critical security settings device
integrity and hundreds of other signals
which we'll look at and I'll show you
some examples of how that's interpreted
next is safety net developer API s and
this is an area we've been investing a
lot of in the last year we want to
provide ways for all developers to
interrogate
stated security of devices it's all well
and good for us to say Android is secure
but actually for an app or the any toad
granule device to be able to make good
decisions about app is important and
this is getting more and more important
every year as we see most of the like
many of the critical decisions relating
to security being taken not just at the
operating system level but at the
application level so I'll cover three
different API is in this session which I
think could be a value at last we have
Android device manager if I was to rank
these four in order of importance this
would clearly be at the top this is
addressing the largest for ask Android
users face when it comes to the security
and that risk is of course losing its
own while we spend a lot of time and we
will in this talk thinking about harmful
apps or bases of attacks throughout
here's that the average Android user
will never encounter one of these but
nearly every Android user will at some
point in this place lose or have their
phone stolen so we need to have a tool
to help users out in that in that
occasion so Android device manager is
our tool to offer peace of mind in their
time of need
and I'll show you a little bit about
that towards the end of the talk so the
good news about all of these features is
that they are available across most
active Android devices there's no need
to have a new version of Android to use
them but those on top of the platforms
are deployed through Google Play
services and the Google Play Store and
they're constantly updating so I hope it
comes with good news that users they
need to be buying a new phone to get
these protections in fact a lot of the
work we do is making sure that users who
are running older versions of the
operating system potentially ones that
aren't receiving security updates will
will still get the core protections
here's the scale at which we operate
we're protecting over 1.4 billion
devices all the time
unique thing about safety net is that we
have an unparalleled view into the
Android ecosystem to spot when things go
wrong and to your protection we spotted
normal ease and we can see trends that
are emerging we scan devices pretty
rigorously we're currently at about 750
million device scans a day it's also
given this talk a couple of months ago
that number would have been 400 million
we're ramping up very aggressively and
I'll show you how that works in a bit
but let's begin by talking about apps
we're scanning over 6 billion of them
daily the Google Play Store is a
cornerstone of security for the Android
ecosystem Google Play allows users to
get the most out their devices by
getting apps that they they want to use
to enable communication or games and so
forth it's also enabling new business
models for developers giving them access
to a vast audience of potential
consumers with over a million apps on
Google Play and 65 billion downloads
ensuring the safe distribution of these
apps is imperative so this diagram
describes at a very high level this
security lifecycle all apps does this
distributed via Play so we begin at the
top left where apps arrive on the Play
Store this is where a developer will
upload an app in the form of an apk file
to the Google Play Developer console to
have been able to do this the developer
will attempt to sign up for a publisher
account that will accept the Play
Developer distribution agreement and
they'll have to pay a registration fee
and for that registration you have been
verified details from the Google account
that was used and billing information
will have been used to to to process
that registration so once the apps
uploaded before EA is actually published
it passes through our comprehensive
review and analysis pipeline the first
step of this is manual policy review and
every app that's published to Google
Play is manually reviewed by a human
for policy inspection so this point
we'll look to see does the app adhere to
Google play's policies and will check a
dozen contain violating content things
like spam or illegal content or
impersonation so once it's passed
through and it's got past that part of
the check we're going to enter our
security analysis part of the pipeline
which is where automated analysis kicks
in this is in the realm of things like
inspecting the code that's inside the
app the file is contained and also
running gap in our emulators I'll give
you a in depth look at what that looks
like in a couple of slides so this
analysis is performed on a wii app and
then it passes to our score engine and
the score engine is really what makes a
decision about whether that is good or
bad either the score engine notices some
behavior which is in line with known bad
behavior in which case the Apple we were
rejected or sometimes it's not sure
about the app it's see something
suspicious and we passed for another
round of manual review at this point we
end up in manual security of users where
it's passed to a an expert in app
security analysis and they will go and
review that app and then make a
determination either rejecting or
approving it and the decisions are taken
by those human analysts feedback into
the score engines future decision-making
so once we've got through this part of
the flow we end up all being well as is
the case for 99% of apps in the
published state sometimes there are
cases where we spotted funder abilities
in the apps that aren't intentionally
harmful perhaps the developer has
included a vulnerable version of the
library an example that would be a few
include a version of OpenSSL that's old
and it's vulnerable to the log an attack
so we would actually in this pipeline
also exposed to the developer in the
developer console the information about
that app saying hey you should probably
go and fix this issue and so there are
there are numerous such vulnerabilities
that we will alert developers to
so this process is paralyzed meaning
that most apps going from upload to the
published state get barren just a couple
of hours or less but it doesn't end
there every app is constantly
resubmitted through this pipeline going
being reanalyzed and rescored
every day and the score engine is
augmented with data from the sensor
network this is what I referred to the
previous slide where the sensor network
in Android devices is reporting back how
those apps are behaving so you can think
about it where we have the dynamic sort
of analysis happening in the in Google's
cloud where we're emulating these apps
we actually have a lot of data coming
back from real devices running as apps
real selves verify apps is an app is
determined to be harmful verify apps
operating on devices make sure that no
instances of mapper installed it'll warn
users about the app if it's installed
already it will prompt them to uninstall
and verify apps prevents the app from
being installed if it's distributed
outside of play as well and this is
where it gets really exciting because
this just process for Google Play have
actually applied mostly as I've shown
here for apps that we find outside of
Google Play - in fact over 90% of apps
that are installed from unknown sources
or pre-loaded app stores or any other
any other source have passed through our
security analysis pipelines so I've
alerted to collapse but I thought it'd
be worth of thinking about what actually
is a novel app by Google we use the term
potentially harmful apps to talk about
apps that we consider harmful on Android
and a potentially harmful app is an app
that poses a potential security risk to
users their device or data and we see
this breaking down into two main
categories those that abused API s
and those that are exploit
vulnerabilities in the platform with API
abuse we see apps that use Android API s
and they operate within the android
security model
to to perform a behavior that could be
considered harmful an example of this
would be a phishing app those fishing
apps aren't exploiting the platform
they're using standard Android API s2
and UI widgets to draw a convincing
looking login screen to fish for
credentials and this category of app in
the realm of API abuse is by far the
most common over 90% of PHAs that we see
are in the realm of an API abuse and
social engineering the other category
would be described as exploit this is
where you're taking advantage of a gap
or a hole that has been unpatched in
Android an example of this would be
routing where people root the device or
privilege escalation where you might
break outside of the application sandbox
in some other way and this is less
common as I say fewer than 10% and if
you're running a Android device that has
got the latest security patches
typically these sorts of PHAs are
ineffective
nearly every PHA we see is trying to
make money in some way and so it's
frankly much simpler to do that as a
malware officer by going down the API
abuse part and the unique thing about
our security team is that we of course
we're not just looking at what's going
wrong and then trying to go and catch
those apps we're able to affect change
in the Android platform so where we see
API abuse we can go and improve the
api's in future versions of Android an
example of that would be we've seen
quite a lot of malware that take uses
the device admin API is to try and take
the device hostage prevent prevent
themselves from peanut installed and so
in Android n there were some
improvements those ap is to remove that
sort of behavior that was being commonly
abused so with that in mind I'll now
dive into more detail here about this
app analysis and this is really looking
at the core of our app risk analyzer
I'll talk about just a few of the
specifics so we begin with static
analysis
this is where we go and eventually
decompile the app look at the static
code and we match that against known
patterns that are considered harmful we
extract features and let's just look at
everything that's contained within the
apk file the next part dynamic analysis
is a lot more exciting now this is where
we run the applications in our emulators
every app we get hold of runs in our
emulators in the cloud in a real Android
environment this is how we detect
behavior that couldn't be seen through
static analysis alone we one of the
things like network connection or
interaction with other services on the
device to come to us to come to a
determination about behavior that could
be considered harmful
I mentioned third-party reports here we
would never claim that our we're
catching a hundred percent of all bad
apps we're always trying having to
improve it and one of the things that
the Android security team is build out
it's very active relationships with the
research community as always being
provided with information that helps us
improve this detection so we have
academic academic institutions security
companies internet of researchers who
all tipping us off about new types of
badass they find we build the
protections into this analyzer service
so fostering those relationships is very
important developer relations developer
relationships this is where of course
when we see apps either through Play or
even outside of play we try and match
the link between those developers
through players of course a little bit
easier because we have Google accounts
and we'll try and find the relationships
between those accounts other activities
the form or Google properties and we
find a link between apps even outside a
play features of the app such as the
signing certificate or even the
structure of the app itself gives us a
clue as to the link between developers
and helps us incriminate apps based on
other apps from the same developer next
we have the sensor network and this is
what I mentioned this is a feedback loop
for devices on the field this really is
the unique thing about our analysis
we're really able to augment what we see
with the behavior apps for real
the feedback comes into the risk
analyzer and helps us identify apps that
maybe weren't exhibiting that horrible
behavior in the emulators and similarity
analysis that of course most harmful
apps use we see are not brand new
they're not unique strategies that have
been taken and so we're able to compare
the features of the code to see what
they look like other ones we've
previously Flags and we're not doing
this on a whim we have 20,000 dedicated
CPUs running 24 hours a day seven days a
week
operating this pipeline each day we're
analyzing over half a million apps as I
mentioned we get not just on Google Play
and in the last 30 days we've pulled
apps from over 100,000 different
websites and increasingly we're able to
turn to new forms of analysis machine
learning models operating in our app
brisk analyzer port over 50 percent of
harmful apps that was submitted to
Google Play in the last month alone I
will show you an example of that later
on so with that in mind what's the end
result that would be useless if we
didn't think it's having an effect at
most conferences in the technology world
you're led to expect that all charts
should be going up into the right so I'm
sorry to disappoint you this one is
looking rather flat but that's a good
reason contrary to many of the reports
in the media mobile malware is not the
next major threat to civilization so
this chart shows the percentage of
android devices which have a known
potentially harmful app installed over
the last couple of years and you'll see
at the end of 2016 and we will hovering
and in fact declining a little bit
around 0.69% that's less than 1% of
devices that we've detected a
potentially harmful app installed and
that's the overall tha rank for the
ecosystem we can break it down in many
ways that give us a little bit more
nuance into that into that seeker for
example this huge Geographic and
variation here
one of the big focus areas for our team
has been looking at PHA campaigns
operating in the Southeast Asia region
especially on very low-end phones where
perhaps they're not certified Android
devices some of them are even coming
with malware preloaded on on the device
at the store and so that's that's
something we're working really hard to
tackle in fact of the uncertified
unapproved Android devices they have a
500% higher chance of seeing a
potentially harmful app installed
so if we split into those users who are
installing from Google Play and those
who are not and using other sources we
see another stark contrast the Google
Play figure is the line of a bottom here
while we see that just 0.05 percent of
devices have encountered the potentially
harmful app and if you're operating
inside a managed environment of course
you can inform where your users end up
on this sort of chart you can decide to
restrict your users to install from the
Play Store you can even go a step
further and if you're in a managed
profile by using the managed play
features to restrict the App Store
available so I hope this is reassuring
in that the instances of malware that we
see are really quite rare in the next in
a few weeks time we're going to be
releasing our 2016 annual Android
security year review so I'd encourage
you to go and check that out because
that includes many more insights like
these and lots of other data from last
year so based on having identified
harmful apps what actually happens on
devices the screen on the right is what
you'd see if you are trying to install
an own PHA from an unknown source or
from a third-party store as a reminder
of course if we detect any PHA the app
will no longer be distributed through
Google Play so it install time a user
would never need to be worried about
installing a hub flap from the Play
Store
we verify every installation that
happens outside of Google Play that
includes any om stool that's preloaded
any carrier store or unknown sources as
installs from third-party app stores
that the user might have downloaded or
from file-sharing peer-to-peer or the
web and the result of this is a verify
apps will either warm block or approve
the install this dialog is showing Adams
early warning user there are some types
of files lapse that we allow the user to
proceed with installation in fact if you
were to click more details here you
would see there is a button that allows
you to go and install the app and
sometimes we get asked like why do we
allow users to install harmful apps and
the answer that is that not every
potentially harmful app is not wanted by
the user but the most clear example of
that would be routing apps where there
are some number of Android users who
would like to try and route their device
to try and get new you capabilities and
so are our warning dialogues are mindful
of that and when we're not we're not
restricting that sort of behavior in the
ecosystem we perform a lot of UX
experiments with these dialogues in fact
we reshuffled the screen that you see
here at the end of 2015 to hide that
install anyway button under the more
details that we instantly saw a 50%
reduction in the number of harmful apps
been installed so we are trying very
hard to make sure that users do the
right thing and we're not just warning
on app so we know to be harmful
sometimes we'll have other clues that
help us identify whether this install
might be of concern an example that
would be if we know it's been installed
by an unusual UID Linux UID it's not
coming from an app for a process that we
expect to have the permission to install
an app or maybe we see the install being
triggered by another harmful app we
would warn the user in that case and to
give you a sense of scale you might be
wondering how often do we show these
things so I I looked at the numbers for
the for the length of time that I'm
talking today
for yesterday at the same time of day we
showed a hunt 1000 of these warnings to
people in the US if it's not is not
disproportionately large that gives you
an idea of how how frequently we're
having to warn about hull flaps and the
flipside of
survey apps is the periodic scans all
installed apps regardless of origin are
routinely checked for PHAs when we find
the PHA we put it into the stop state
and make sure the app isn't running
anymore and then we either warn the user
or remove the app entirely now this
notification on the right is what
happens only warning users are about PHA
that's been found that's an install
button blur or they can tap the
notification to find out more and
uninstalling PHAs is made easy by the
application sandbox the fact that apps
are contained within an application
sandbox means that our installing apps
is not a very complicated task we're
able to break cleanly remove them from
devices so the last year and a half
we've been scanning every device in
Russia daily for PHAs that would tackle
some very persistent SMS fraud campaigns
and we saw a huge improvement in the PHA
rates or so Russia in doing so and so
we're excited started this year to now
be expanding that coverage to every
Android device in the world so every
device will be checking for installed
PHAs daily in just a few weeks time and
so verify it isn't just operating there
behind the scenes without you knowing as
an application developer so I'm excited
to show you some new API is that are
coming and the forthcoming release of
Google Play services that you could
inspect the state of verify apps and
take control so we have an API called is
verify apps enabled it essentially does
what it says on the tin verify apps is
enabled by default for anyone who signs
in to Android device with a Google
account or use a Google Play Store and
so anyone who doesn't fall into either
of those groups but who's side loads app
installs my own sources they'll be
to enable vampires at each time of a
install so you can check if their
implants is enabled if not you can call
the enable verify apps API that will
prompt the user to enable verify apps
and we have the list holes lapse API
that will tell you about any known
harmful app so the user has willingly
installed on that device and I'll give
you a code example in a second
I mentioned finally that today already
the platform has a restriction that you
can put in place if you are able to use
the device policy manager API for a
managed device to ensure that Vera
laughs enabled that's that forces our
maps to be be turned on the user
couldn't choose to go and turn it off so
this is the list collapse API it's
incredibly straightforward to use and it
removes the need for you to necessarily
build your own hacky solutions based on
blacklisting package names or other sort
of apps matching or sending that back to
your server a use case here you could
consider as if your enterprise app you
might want to be auditing for any
harmful apps that are installed on user
devices you could call this API and send
the results back to your server as I
mentioned this API is part of Google
Play services and you will use it by
connecting to the facing our API client
through the Google API classes so it
returns the time of the last scan with
the get last scan time function that'll
always be within the last 24 hours
and we ensure that when you're calling
this API there is a fresh scan available
if for some reason Sarah Pownall is not
enabled of course at this stage you
could then go and caulk enable verify
apps API to make sure it was turned on
and then we have yet hull's laps list
this is a very underwhelming API call
99.5% of the time it will return
absolutely nothing at all will be empty
left but let's take a look at what
happens if there was to be something
there so there's a list of harmful apps
data objects and it contains information
about an app to identify the harmful one
and you can send us back your server for
example so first we have a category and
this is used to define what type of
harmful apps
it is an example of this could be
fishing or trojan or SMS fraud or
routing and we published our
classifications of PHAs online you can
search for our whitepaper and it's also
documented in the API documentation and
then to identify the specific app we
include the package name of the app as
well as the sha-256 hash of the apk file
and I've included an example at the
bottom here of what that could look like
here we have a fishing app and its
package name and digest the digest is a
way of uniquely identifying that apk
file so with that covered let's talk
about the sensor network I think this is
one of the more exciting parts because
it operates so behind the scenes it will
typically know about it so I'm glad to
share some of that with you today on the
right you see of warning dialog with
popups when a user or an app tries to
send a message to a premium rate SMS
number we ask you if you really want to
send this and the responses to that
dialog
I said back into the sensor network
which helps us to identify apps that
could be performing SMS fraud that's
just one example of the sort of data
that the sensor network picks up
allowing us to identify that apps so the
sensor network is fundamentally this
feedback loops that pipes back into our
app risk analyzer helping us to identify
new threats in a sense safety net is
looking and keeping an eye on what
happens on our device after the absence
tool to make sure it doesn't step out of
line and the changes in state on that
device can be attributed back to the app
that was just installed there are
hundreds of signals some of them are
listed here for example exploit attempt
logging system integrity checks as he
limits enforcement network probes or
checking them in the middle attacks that
sort of thing SMS denials and the core
system security settings so let's see
one example we perform statistical
analysis and publicus and of course
operating at such huge scale across
flavor billion Android devices allows us
to spot anomalies when they crop up
so this is one one scorer now that
features in the score engine called the
dead or insecure score and what this
tracks is how some devices disappear off
our radar once an app is installed
typically we expect that when you
install an app that device should carry
on checking back in with the sensor
network the next day and the next day in
the next day and so we measure for each
app what the probability of that device
checking back in the next day is and so
we look and compare that with the
ecosystem average of course there is
some drop-off every day from normal
device usage maybe I'm going to go and
buy a new phone but perhaps where that
this is significantly from the from the
norm we can go and investigate that app
all very clearly identified the app was
doing something in all of us and so this
is what we use to go and flag flag new
apps but cause devices to go dark maybe
because they try and turn off safety net
or maybe they break the device so
fundamentally that the user has to go in
factory reset it and there's been very
effective in detecting you new routing
campaigns and people who looked at such
as humming battle goes Bush you can
publish a blog post about this so if you
want to go search for it you can just
search for dead or insecure score of
course we're not just limited to
conventional statistical analysis
machine learning is playing an
increasingly key role in how we find
hard laps what you see here is a
clustering of apps of harmful apps based
on their installed patterns generated
generated with a neural network using
tensor flow this uses the techniques
called word embeddings which is pioneers
in the field field of a natural language
processing but applying it to apps
instead in a sense the order in which
apps are installed it's quite similar to
the order in which words are constructed
in sentences and so we can use the
ordering of app installs to discern
something about the apps themselves so
the result of this neural network is a
vector for every app and app sectors are
positioned in vector space such that
apps that share common contexts or
attributes or patterns show up in a
similar area or vector space so for
example we'd expect to find all the
messaging apps showing up in one part of
excess space or all of the gaming apps
in another cluster and this is true for
PHAs too so in this 2d embedding you see
here we colored in all of the
potentially harmful apps and our
different categories and you see that
they cluster in sometimes quite tight
groups for example in the top left we
have a light blue section those are all
SMS fraud apps hopefully you can see how
we're able to use this very powerfully
to detect new types of harmful behavior
for a new app that we haven't yet been
able to classify if we see that it's
embedding in vector space shows up
within that cluster we can begin to
highly suspect the app is also being
part of an SMS fraud campaign approaches
like these are greatly improving our
ability to detect new types of harm so
let's take a look at the app station API
this is one of the most frequent API
that I discuss with enterprises and
developers I think it could be
powerfully used maybe for some of your
use cases to the screen here shows
Android pay deciding that it hasn't been
able to determine the device security
sufficiently to be able to run they use
gas station API to determine this many
apps have questions such as is the app
talking to my server tonight like is
actually my app can I trust the platform
ad is is a genuine device is my app
running on a rooted phone it is the safe
net station API but allowing to assess
the security compatibility of the
Android environments in which your apps
are running
so briefly talk you through how this
works at a high level what happens is
you'll call the attestation API on a
device and then we will run through
safety-net a series of checks to come to
a decision about the device state the
results will come back from a Google
server as a signed statement as the
device integrity and compatibility and
then you can inspect that signed
statement on a device you trust that's
normally your server to decide whether
or not you're going to trust that app or
that device so you need both client and
server-side implementations so you begin
by calling the app taskmaster to state
an API also in Google Play services with
a nonce of single-use token identifies
that request that token will have been
sent by your server and then that's the
end of what you're going to do on your
device when you get the result back you
send Matt your server you're using the
gas station to decide if you trust the
device you don't want to be doing any
checks on the device itself so now on
the server side you pass back this
result it's in the form of a JSON web
signature and so if you want to validate
the jws so the first step is validating
the SSL certificate chain and checking
the belief certificate matches what was
issues to Google Android calm and then
you'll verify to that that certificate
was used to sign the jws now you can
look at the actual content to the jws
which I'm showing on the right here
you'll check the nonce matches the one
that you requested you'll check the
timestamp is accepted Lee close to where
you put your request time all right and
then you can check the details about
Gant itself you can check does the
package name of the app match why an app
does the signing certificate hash match
Lyon app even goes the digest of the apk
file itself match the apk that I
produced this helps you determine on
your server whether the Android app that
is talking to you is really yours
sometimes we won't include the ADK
information and that's because we can't
determine with any reliability over that
is your app maybe maybe it's a a random
script that is not even running on
Android at all and then you look at the
last few fields we have the CTF profile
match and basic integrity and those are
really the key results here cts profile
matches telling you is this device
definitely a device that has been
approved and certified all devices that
are published produced with Google
services on them I have to go through
some rigorous certification as you can
check is led by device and you can
restrict the operation of your app to
those devices and then we have the basic
integrity field which is a slightly
weaker check than GPS profile match
that's now ignoring whether or not the
device is certified and just checking
those the basic intake skier that this
device looks like it is a compatible
real Android device
it's not being tampered with in any way
so we've got Co don't get help that I'll
help you out with this if you want to go
check it out I encourage you to go and
see if this answers some of your
questions that you might have the like
many apps are using their own basic
route checks or integrity check some
device which are truly bypassed and so
safe now station is the solution for
that work see paying close attention to
how how well is is working looking at
researchers who are trying to bypass
such restrictions and as far as we can
tell it's holding up pretty well in fact
one of the challenges you may face if
you're operating a service but crosses
many different platforms is that you're
you're always limited by the weakest
client that is going to talk to your
server so we start to see maybe Android
apps that start to impersonate iOS apps
or Wintle windows apps or web clients to
try and communicate with your your
server endpoints
another API that we exposes Safe
Browsing Safe Browsing is a Google
service that's operated for many years
but let's applications check whether a
given URL is potentially harmful with it
you can check pages again Safe Browsing
different threats black lists you could
warn users before they click on a link
or you could prevent users from sharing
unsafe links and on the right you see
the Chrome browser which integrates with
the safety net Safe Browsing API for
every URL that is loaded in Chrome and
here they're warning a user because it
looks like this page distributes malware
will say browsing any guy is very
straightforward it's pretty much the
code I've shown here you first have to
register an API key we can get on the
Google cloud console and then you call
lookup URI with the URL and the threat
types that you are concerned about at
the moment we have social engineering
and potentially harmful apps and then we
give you a result which is whether or
not that URL matched any other known
threat types this is a case where most
of the time you'll also return an empty
list in which case that's good news and
the Safe Browsing API is designed to be
privacy preserving and bandwidth
sufficient the URL with your checking
with the Safe Browsing API is never sent
off the device so this is a really great
way of maintaining the privacy as that
that link
we're also frequently syncing the
blacklist on device in a very efficient
way so it's not consuming resources or
bandwidth are necessarily for the user
so last we jump to Android device
manager if you haven't used it I
encourage you to go and check it out
Android device manager is this tool
allows you to find locate ring wipe any
Android device and it's built into every
device Android device running Google
services by default there's no setup
needed all you need to do is sign in to
the Google account and then it's enabled
in fact is you don't even have to have
an app installed in your device
and you're able to go and load up the
website or install the Android app to go
and ring lock or raise any devices that
your account is identi and we have
integrations with Google search so if
you were signed into your Google account
at Google search and you go and search
find my phone will show you a one box
result showing where your phone is
or maybe you have an Android wear watch
and you've misplaced your phone but you
can use your watch to ring your phone to
that's all part of Android device
manager and this works from Android 2.3
app so it's enabled for pretty much
every device that is active today and
we're locating hundreds of thousands of
phones every single day so with that
that's brought us to the end of my
survey of all the components of safety
net we talked about verify apps which is
harmful app detection and removal the
sensor network which is providing
security Mouse telemetry helping us to
identify all apps
the powerful developer API is allowing
you to inspect the security of a device
and make decisions and Android device
manager lost device protection and the
exciting thing about this is that it's
updating all the time whenever whenever
we come and present what's going on with
all something new to add we're working
every day to develop these and deploy
new versions to offer better protection
to users without them having to pay for
anything so before I take any questions
and just to remind if you're interested
in knowing more about how either Android
or Chrome or Google cloud fits into your
enterprise environment you can go and
visit this not particularly to pass link
to learn more about our connected
workspace information and sign up to get
advanced access apps to some of our
upcoming reports such as the Android
security year review with that ok thank
you for attending and I'll be around for
any questions
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]